I would never get too hung up on
mistakes I make mistakes all the time I
need the stage learn from their mistakes
we have to learn from our mistakes I
continually learn from my mistakes learn
from your mistakes
hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to cover how you can
learn from your mistakes and as always
guys if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well and when you write
it down it's much more likely to stick
to yourself to enjoy I was just
wondering what is what would you
consider to be the worst investment
you've ever made the worst investment I
ever made how long do you have
[Applause]
I've made some very bad ones but that
doesn't really bother me I am they
bother the shareholders but that's
another question see you know you're
going to make you're gonna make mistakes
in life I mean there's no question about
it you know want to make them on the big
decisions you know who you marry and
says and things like that so there's no
way I'm going to make a lot of business
and investment decisions without making
some mistakes I may try to minimize them
I don't I don't dwell on them at all I
don't I don't look back that the biggest
mistakes are the ones that actually
don't show up they're the mistakes of
omission rather than commission we've
never lost that much money on any one
investment but it's the things that I
knew enough to do that I didn't do we
have we have missed profits of as much
as you know maybe 10 billion dollars and
things that I knew enough to do and I
didn't do now the fact I didn't by
Microsoft way back is not a forgone
opportunity because I didn't know enough
to make that decision but there have
been other investments where I did know
enough to make the decision and for one
reason or another I either didn't do it
at all or I did it on a small
scale I was sucking my thumb when I
should have been writing checks you know
basically and and and you know those
don't show up there's no place where it
shows missed opportunities but I've
missed some big ones the triumphs in
life are partly trying because you know
that everything isn't going to be a
triumph and and and I would never get
too hung up on mistakes I know a lot of
people that really agonize over them and
it just isn't worth it I mean tomorrow's
another day and you live it forward and
just go on to the next thing so when
people come up to me and say Gary it's
so hard I look at their Instagram and
they're not posting any of their content
with hashtags which is a by accident way
to pick up exposure in a world where
they have no money when you have no
money when I took over my dad's business
it did three million dollars a year ten
percent gross profit three hundred
thousand dollars before expenses my
first year marketing budget was fourteen
thousand dollars when you have no money
and I built that business from a three
to a sixty million dollar business in
five years I had to make every penny
perfect so I was right about email
marketing in ninety six and I was right
and because of that I had ninety one
percent open rates when Google AdWords
came out the day it came out I paid five
cents a click for words before anybody
bid me up and I was super right and that
worked this is that lack of preparation
and you ever get anything wrong what do
you do I get a commit I give everything
wrong it's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong I'm moving on to
the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you stopped
on is the quickest way for the next
thing not to work right yeah
so like so I think I do everything I
mean you know this this is a fun thing
to say some people in the back know this
I was a breakout youtube star in the
first year 2006 I decided that the right
strategy was to leave YouTube completely
and go to viddler because viddler
offered me equity in their company and
I've left an enormous amount of
attention iDVD for my intention thisis
to do short-term economics and equity in
a company and I lost I lost Wendy Brock
finally came in my life two years ago we
started to try to build up my YouTube
for the first time I was sitting on
40,000 user followers in a world record
I've had millions if I just stayed the
course so I make mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
about my mistakes everybody else cares
about your mistakes if you're worried
about your own mistakes you've already
lost you know I never want to be always
right because then there can't grow I
can't learn so I have no desire to be
always right I need mistakes you know
rent and luckily enough and not going on
this wimpy angle here that like you know
my mistakes are never crucial enough for
me to be like you know they're always
great learning experiences before you
succeed you must first learn to fail a
lot of people have failed if they get
down on themselves but the best of
sports stars learn from their mistakes
though I shouldn't do this
okay we'll do that next you you just
keep learning until you get to the point
to review the champion then everybody
else to co-teach you should be eight
years before grammar for a championship
and after that one three in a row lost
key and I got another one
and it's get loose so it's not easy but
you know it's not a it's not a specific
time period of how long it takes you to
sort of norm for your mistakes you make
mistakes that they may just rather
capitalize over earlier this summer you
were in a donut shop you're in
California you said some hurtful things
about Americans and about people's
weight a lot of people watching felt
offended by your words what do you want
to say first of all I mean my behavior
was very offensive and I apologized
there is no excuse or there is nothing
to justify it but you know I think that
as human beings we all say and do things
that we don't mean at all sometimes and
we have to learn from it I mean that's
part of our process we have to learn
from our mistakes and that's how we grow
I continually learn from my mistakes and
other people's mistakes
the entrepreneurs think that hey to
create that billion dollar company 100
million dollar company or even million
our company had to be really smart and
sure brains is part of it
luck is a huge component but what I've
learned over the years is everyone no
matter how smart you are you're going to
fail many times you're going to make
mistake just with your marker dr. Berg
Facebook where
about his version of snapchat that was a
copycat did not work out right so
there's other areas in which Facebook
failed but Facebook overall the company
has been great just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're always going to
succeed with everything you try or touch
but every time you do something you will
learn new things you'll make mistakes
and if you learn from these mistakes and
avoid making them over and over again
you'll actually increase your odds of
succeeding as time goes on
and the best way to do this is not just
to learn from your mistakes there's also
to learn from the mistakes of others
Rockefeller Carnegie all these people
who are entrepreneurs years ago in the
1800 1900s they themselves use business
principles and concepts that are still
applicable in today's world surely have
the Internet but the same strategies and
concepts that they use are still
applicable right so learn from their
mistakes learn will work for them what
didn't work them why and bring that into
what you're doing today you haven't
gotten every investment right tell me
about the worst misses that you've had
or sort of the biggest setback there
every investment you get into you're
getting in there because you think you
have an airtight case as to why this
thing is going to work out you're
convicted you're passionate you're
putting not just your money in so I put
all your time and effort near your own
brand and your reputation is on the line
and more often than not we're wrong but
even more painful are some of these ones
where I didn't invest at all and they've
gone on to be the mega unicorn I think
about Airbnb and they told me the pitch
about renting out a room in somebody
else's house while the owner was still
there I literally look those guys the
eye and I said guys this is so dangerous
man somebody's going to get laid they're
murdered and the blood is going to be on
your hands I think this is a really bad
idea I think they're currently raising
at a twenty billion dollar valuation now
so it is my fun probably missed out on
hundreds of millions
as a result right you have to learn from
your mistakes no see I have this
attitude that no situation is impossible
there is nothing impossible there just
continued season and obstacles to get
around so if I went out and I'm just
trying to think of my obstacles let's
just say you did an opener and she'd
heard it already you did your line she
heard it already because your friend
just approached it with the ten minutes
ago do you run screaming and maybe that
happens the first time the second time
you say if that happens again what do I
do you say oh my god he must to mind my
friend that's really funny we were just
talking about that
BAM problem solved whatever it may be
say you any problem has a solution
so I kind of had that attitude you know
what if she's with eight guys what if
you know she is on her way out the door
or any problem is going to have a
solution so you have to have that
attitude and if something goes wrong and
I'm saying this in a positive way not a
negative self-esteem way if something
goes wrong it's always your fault that's
what I feel like without being hard of
myself if something goes wrong it's
never her fault she's not a bit she is
not mean she is not uptight I did
something wrong to make her
uncomfortable so for example with the
openers I would start walking up and
saying hey guys I want to get it hitting
on something I got this question I'm
trying to ask and I start asking it by
the notice they were they weren't
listening they were tuning me out
they're kind of giving a bad body
language so I realized what are they
thinking why is that happening what's
happening because I'm standing around
they don't know what I'm going to leave
so I added what's called a time
constraint I'd walk in I'd say hey guys
want to get quick hitting them something
by the way it can only stay for a second
because I got to rejoin my friends over
there you know problem solved so every
anytime something went wrong or was I
coming up maybe I would do everything
and I felt like I was doing them
perfectly but people weren't interested
while I was doing it doing all the right
things but I was doing it in a very
needy way a lot of people will read the
material and they'll say this doesn't
work
everything works what I say is going to
get them in what what zan says and
different than what someone else says it
all works you just have to do it right
so for example the opinion openers we're
talking about an opinion openers how you
start a conversation if you go and say
can I ask you a question on something
and then they say no we're talking get
lost well
the opinion overs don't work you just
did it wrong you walk and say hey guys I
want to ask a quick question on
something now you haven't asked them I
guess no question and it's going to work
there's so many little subtleties did
that make sense
okay so there's so many I saw someone
looking at me strangely so there's
something a little subtle they get to
work in and it's always always going to
be your fault if it's not working not in
a negative way now and being a hard on
yourself it's it's feedback so you can
improve yourself that whole idea there's
no such thing as failure
there's only learning lessons so that's
what I did but you know I'm a guy who's
hard of myself but I'm hard to myself
because it makes me excel usually in a
long time since I told stories about my
boat but Jay and I bought a schooner the
schooner Elizabeth and this was the bell
off from it and it's only important
because the Vote sank she was kind of a
nice little boat but she leaked a lot
that was our first big sailing
experiences but we bought it we won on
that we sank and had long many votes
since then you learn from mistakes you
got started with faith and belief in
yourself is that something you better
make it your business to do knowledge is
priceless
okay even when you make mistakes and you
learn from your birthday I want half a
million dollars I once thought I
invented in my desperate dad's company
in which case we had two prints at home
today they went bankrupt the CEO evil
president CEO bought them in bankruptcy
changed the company name kept all the
same contracts we had to retool the
company for like 30 million I was made
by 10 billion well but I got wiped out
that was a good lesson for me I broke my
trading rules and I didn't really know
you know at the time I was like batting
a thousand and I had that loss so your
loss of your mistakes make you better I
tell this sort of that pink tempers you
know Pete's a majestic
right when he was a junior in I don't
know I want to say 13 14 15 she was one
of the top-ranked players in the US but
his coach had a radical transformation
plan to get him to number one and he
said kick the ball as hard as you can do
you know this girl
hit the ball hard you can in there but
I'm not gonna be able to control it if I
do that right Esther sorry yeah sorry
and the coach would he trust me replay
yeah it's pick up all stories you can't
so for like how about a face to face
nine a month being even a year he hit
the ball as hard as he could and the
balls were flying out he's ranking drops
he was like number six he dropped to
like 200 it's just like nobody right but
then he gradually learned control and he
became their one far and above anybody
else so sometimes you have to like moves
or you know lose your stature effort and
then come back stronger and we come back
so much better but it's tough for people
to accept people just want to accept
like they think it's like gradually
building but they don't we know success
there's a group in the ground got a post
out in genetics like this is success
whatever here but eventually be murder
and everything so you made it to defeat
you weren't if you think not to do any
to wiser but most people learned what
not to do
enemy do not be done half isn't so
frustrating where I can't original thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what was your
biggest takeaway from this video what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Craig
severance in from brightworks PR Craig
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really really
really appreciate it and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon